- I think that we have
a clip of this though.
We have to see this. Okay, show it.
- [Anna] Never know when
you're gonna get stuck
in an elevator.
Did you say "open up the hatch"?
- [Speaker] Yeah.
- [Anna] Everybody watch your head.
- [Speaker] I can't
believe this is happening.
Are you (beep) kidding me?
- Go!
- Come on, we got ya.
- It's a good thing I'm not
wearing a short skirt today.
I know! It was-
- This is my worst nightmare.
You're obviously in an elevator.
- Yeah, so we got stuck in an elevator.
This is the first day of press
at the Toronto Film Festival
for "Alice, Darling."
Yeah, a bunch of us got
stuck in an elevator.
And at first, the elevator jolts
and you all make a little joke about like,
"Can you imagine if we got
trapped in this elevator?"
And then it was like I was in "Die Hard."
They pull you. 'Cause I thought-
- Great Christmas film.
- Yes.
Even though they call the
fire department, you're like,
"Oh, they're gonna pry open
the doors or something."
But we were actually stuck between floors
and we had to do the thing
of getting pulled up through the hatch.
It was very exciting.
It was the most action
star thing I've ever done.
- [Kelly] Is this before
or after your press day?
- This is before. This was like
at the beginning of the day.
So I sat down to start
doing the first press junket
for "Alice, Darling,"
and every journalist that
came in to interview me,
I was like, "Oh, I'm so sorry I'm late,
I was just stuck in this
elevator," and da-da-da.
And all of them just thought like,
"Oh, Anna's funny, so she's doing a bit."
And the more that I was like,
"No, you don't understand,
I literally just now got
pulled out of the ceiling
of the thing, of the
elevator, by firefighters."
And they're like, "She is so funny.
She is really committed to
this bit. She is too funny."
- "You can just say you're
late, girl." (laughs)
Oh my God. That's my worst
nightmare, by the way.
And I always make that joke when I go in,
just so it won't happen.
That's what I literally do
to just trip up the universe.
Like, "Oh, wouldn't it
be funny if it happened?"
and then it doesn't.
- Well, it didn't work for me.
- Yeah, it didn't work for you.
I shall not say it anymore.